given change and they throw it back at
you I mean I don't ever have change on
me anymore all right I'm old in the 90s
I did that I came up I was it was
raining out
and I was running to make my spot and
this guy was sitting in the [__] rain
under scaffolding I was like I could go
dude this is all I got and I just handed
it to him I put in his cup he had a cup
and then I was running away and then I
just heard this change across the thing
and I just he's just down the street
just going [__] yeah
and he was [__] wasted it was before
I realized because I grew up in the
suburbs well you really had to see if
somebody was using I remember I gave a
homeless guy a scone once and he just
goes I don't like scones and I was like
sorry I don't that's what I got
I feel like that's like the same thing
to give them because you're like well
he's not going to buy drugs with us just
like food how much money are you making
that you can turn down food
oh you [__] hate scones
maybe it just really doesn't like scones
I don't know what a scone is it's like a
harder muffin they're pretty good